¿Por qué apoyamos a Ucrania en esta guerra?
O dicho de otra forma ¿Por qué estamos en
contra de Rusia?
Vamos a ser claros; casi todos los medios
de comunicación en Occidente, incluído vuestro
medio favorito, VisualPolitik, damos por sentado
que Putin es el malo de la película y Zelensky
es el bueno.
Paréntesis: por si alguno va a ponerlo en
los comentarios, nunca hemos dicho que Ucrania
sea el paraíso en la tierra.
Es más, tenemos una larga serie de vídeos
donde hemos mostrado la corrupción y todas
las vergüenzas de los políticos ucranianos.
Incluso cuando le dimos un premio VisualPolitik
2021 a Volodymir Zelensky, dejamos bien claro
que ni siquiera podemos garantizar que este
hombre no tenga algún escándalo de corrupción
a sus espaldas.
En cualquier caso…
Todos nuestros vídeos parten de la premisa
de que la invasión de Ucrania es una auténtica
barbaridad en todos los sentidos ¡No sólo
eso!
Partimos de la base de que tanto Europa, como
Estados Unidos como las democracias liberales
de todo el mundo debemos unirnos para frenar
a Putin: hemos hablado de sanciones comerciales,
rearme en Europa y envíos de armas a Ucrania.
Esa es la base de todos nuestros análisis
aquí, en VisualPolitik.
Y muchos os preguntaréis ¿Por qué?
¿De verdad no hay ningún argumento para
defender la postura de Putin?
¿Y si la realidad fuera más compleja que
una historia de buenos y malos?
Pues lo cierto es que… hay argumentos legítimos
para defender la actuación de Putin.
Y no, no vamos a hablar de propagandistas
pro Rusos.
Tampoco vamos a hablar de algún wannabe de
influencer que intenta conseguir fama…
que los hay en todos los países.
Vamos a hablar de analistas políticos de
primer nivel que no estarían para nada de
acuerdo con nosotros.
Gente con un enorme prestigio académico y
político.
Principalmente, este señor que veis aquí…
John Mearsheimer.
Tiene una conferencia titulada “¿Por qué
Ucrania es culpa de Occidente?”
que acumula ya más de 27 millones de visitas
en YouTube ¡Para que luego digan que YouTube
sólo sirve para contenido ligero!.
Pues bien, en este vídeo, vamos a desmontar
muchas de las principales teorías que, de
un modo u otro, critican la actuación de
Occidente y, a su manera, justifican la acción
de Putin.
Como os podéis imaginar, en este vídeo hay
mucha parte de posicionamiento editorial.
Y, por supuesto, hay muchas cosas sobre las
que podéis debatir en los comentarios.
Lo único que os pedimos es que seáis respetuosos.
Porque las preguntas que hoy nos hacemos son
¿Cuáles son las principales teorías anti
OTAN en esta guerra de Ucrania?
¿Por qué creemos que son incorrectas?
¿Cuáles pensamos que son los mayores mitos
de la invasión de Ucrania?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
T1 (IDEALISMO vs REALPOLITIK)
Seguro que muchos habréis visto la charla
de John Mershmeiher.
Si no la habéis visto, os dejamos el enlace
en la descripción.
Lo primero que tenemos que entender es que
este hombre representa una ideología muy
concreta en relaciones internacionales.
Es uno de los principales representantes del
llamado ”REALISMO político” ¿Y qué
defienden los llamados “realistas”?
Según su teoría, el mundo es una anarquía
donde cada estado se rige por sus propios
intereses.
A diferencia de los liberales, los realistas
creen que es casi imposible lograr cooperación
entre estados basándose en principios éticos.
Las relaciones se fundamentan en un juego
de suma cero, donde unos ganan y otros pierden.
Lógicamente, en semejante anarquía prima
la ley del más fuerte.
Pues bien, bajo este prisma, Rusia está respondiendo
a la expansión de la OTAN, que supone una
amenaza existencial contra su seguridad.
Atentos a esta mapa.
La pregunta que habría que plantearse es…
¿De verdad se puede hablar de “la expansión
de la OTAN”?
(((HACER GESTO DE COMILLAS CON LOS DEDOS)))
¡Lo cierto es que no!
Hay una diferencia entre expandir una organización,
es decir, intentar que otros estados entren…
o, simplemente, abrir la puerta a quien quiera
entrar.
Por el momento, la OTAN no ha obligado a ningún
país miembro a entrar en la unión.
De ser así, Austria o Irlanda serían miembros
desde hace muchísimos años.
En realidad, son los países miembros quienes
han decidido unirse.
Hablamos de gobiernos democráticos que han
solicitado su adhesión por motivos de seguridad.
La OTAN se ha limitado a aceptarlos.
En cualquier caso…
Muchos realistas dirían: vale, sea como sea,
el hecho de que tantos países vecinos de
Rusia entren en una alianza militar que antagoniza
con Moscú es una amenaza.
Y aquí es donde entra el argumento que muchos
habréis oído hasta la saciedad estos días…
Estados Unidos no toleraría que México o
Canadá entrarán en una alianza militar liderada
por China o Rusia.
Y aquí es donde entramos en condicionales
¿Qué pasaría si México entrara en una
alianza militar liderada por China?
Está claro que Washington intentaría evitarlo.
La pregunta es ¿Llegarían hasta el punto
de invadirlo?
Tenemos un pequeño precedente: Cuba.
Cuba está al lado de Estados Unidos.
Durante décadas, Cuba estuvo bajo la órbita
soviética.
Incluso llegaron a protagonizar la famosa
crisis de los misiles en el año 1962.
En ese caso, la Unión Soviética estaba colocando
misiles balísticos en Cuba.
Se solucionó de forma diplomática.
Desde entonces, está claro que las relaciones
entre Washington y la Habana son de todo menos
amistosas.
Pero por el momento, nunca hemos visto al
ejército americano invadir la isla.
Ni siquiera tras la disolución de la URSS.
Sin embargo, en este caso, todo empieza con
este hecho.
(“La OTAN da la bienvenida a las aspiraciones
euroatlánticas de Ucrania y Georgia para
su membresía en la OTAN.
Hoy estamos de acuerdo en que estos países
llegarán a ser miembros de la OTAN”
--Párrafo 23 de la declaración de la OTAN
en la cumbre de Budapest de 2008)
¡Exacto!
La OTAN abría sus puertas a Ucrania.
Y sí, esto era una provocación para Rusia.
La pregunta es ¿De verdad es razonable pensar
que Ucrania iba a unirse?
Lo hemos tratado varias veces en VisualPolitik:
no.
De entrada, la mayoría de su población estaba
en contra.
En el año 2010, el 51% de los ucranianos
decía “NO” a la OTAN para evitar provocar
a Rusia ¡Pero no sólo eso!
Como ya hemos contado en varios vídeos de
VisualPolitik, el ejército de Ucrania no
cumplía ninguno de los estándares de la
unión.
Empezando porque estaba desgastado por años
de corrupción.
Recordad que en el año 2014, durante la invasión
de Crimea, ni siquiera tenían ropa con la
que vestir a los soldados.
Dicho de otra forma, la OTAN arriesgaba mucho
y ganaba poco.
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos: si la OTAN
no tenía claro que Ucrania fuera a entrar...
¿Por qué hicieron esa declaración?
¿Por qué provocar a Rusia?
Pues sí, ese es un argumento totalmente válido.
Y aquí, el señor Mershmeiher tiene toda
la razón.
De hecho, la solución que proponía para
evitar la guerra que hoy estamos viviendo
es muy realista.
Atentos.
Desde luego, esta es una postura muy legítima.
Y es difícil rebatirla.
Sobre todo en el año en el que se hizo esta
charla: el año 2015.
Por aquel momento era fácil pensar que Putin
se limitaba a buscar la neutralidad de Ucrania
y nada más.
Incluso el propio Mershmeiher lo pensaba.
Atentos.
Sin embargo, la realidad ha echado por tierra
incluso las tesis más “realistas” Putin
ha hecho exactamente lo que nadie se esperaba:
intentar tomar toda Ucrania empezando por
Kyiv.
Vamos a recordar lo que ha ocurrido desde
entonces.
La guerra de Ucrania estalló en el año 2014.
Ese año, Ucrania no estaba pidiendo la entrada
en la OTAN ni muchísimo menos.
En realidad, lo que desató las iras de Putin
fue ESTO:
(Acuerdo de asociación entre la UE y Ucrania
¿Firmar o no firmar?)
¡Exacto!
Estamos hablando de un acuerdo comercial con
la Unión Europea.
Un acuerdo que desató unas protestas contra
el gobierno prorruso que había en Kyev.
Muchos quieren pensar que estas protestas
fueron un golpe de estado auspiciado por Estados
Unidos.
Pero, vamos a ser claros: Ucrania ya tenía
una enorme población proeuropea en 2014.
Y buena parte de esta población vivía en
la capital.
Es decir: es bastante realista pensar que
fueron muchos de estos ucranianos quienes,
con o sin ayuda de Estados Unidos, se levantaron
contra su gobierno.
Dicho de otra forma: no hace falta la intervención
de Estados Unidos para explicar cualquier
fenómeno.
Pero recordad que ni siquiera se trataba de
la entrada de Ucrania en la Unión Europea.
Y alguno dirá ¡Hombre, Fonseca!
Pero firmar un acuerdo de libre comercio con
Europa implica entrar en la OTAN…
¿No?
Pues realmente no.
Ahí tenéis el ejemplo de Austria, Irlanda,
Finlandia o Suecia: todos ellos son miembros
de pleno derecho en la Unión Europea.
Ninguno de estos 4 países es miembro de la
OTAN.
Y, hasta este año, ni Suecia ni Finlandia
se planteaban entrar.
Dicho de otra forma: en ningún momento estamos
diciendo que Ucrania tuviera cabezas nucleares
apuntando contra Rusia.
Todas las hostilidades de Rusia empezaron
por un acuerdo comercial ¡Y esperad un momento
porque esta no es la primera vez que Rusia
ha tenido conflictos con Ucrania!
Básicamente, cada vez que los ucranianos
han elegido gobiernos que no eran del gusto
del Kremlin, toda Europa ha tenido problemas
con el suministro de gas ruso.
Lo vimos en 2005 y en 2008.
Dicho de otra forma: desatar las iras de Putin
es realmente fácil.
Ahora la pregunta que nos deberíamos hacer
es ¿De verdad un acuerdo de libre comercio
con Europa es una crisis existencial para
Rusia?
Y la respuesta de Mearsheimer es esta.
La pregunta ahora es ¿Es este un planteamiento
correcto?
Desde luego, tiene mucho sentido.
Ahora bien, si asumimos esto, tendremos que
asumir que Ucrania no es un estado soberano.
Ni Ucrania ni ningún país pequeño.
Esto no es ningún argumento de hombre de
paja.
Lo reconoce el propio Mershmeiher.
Dicho de otra forma: la ley del más fuerte.
Bajo este principio, Ucrania tendría que
aceptar cualquier condición de Rusia.
No sólo hablamos de neutralidad militar sino
de acuerdos comerciales o incluso gobiernos.
Y ya sé lo que pensaréis muchos ¡El mundo
funciona así: es triste pero es la realidad!
Y sí, puede que tengáis razón.
Pero tened muy clara una cosa: asumir esta
posición implica aceptar que hay países
destinados a ser colonias.
Es decir, estamos hablando de obligar a 40
millones de ucranianos a no poder elegir el
partido de gobierno que quieran, negociar
los acuerdos comerciales que quieran y vivir
bajo sus propias condiciones.
Esto no es ser neutral: es aceptar no tener
soberanía y ser una colonia de Moscú ¡No
sólo eso!
Implica aceptar que Occidente tampoco puede
elegir sus socios comerciales.
Todo para evitar desatar las iras de Rusia.
Y la pregunta es ¿Es realista para Rusia
pensar que Ucrania y Occidente van a evitar
estas condiciones?
En el caso de Ucrania, ya hemos visto que
no.
Son los propios ucranianos quienes han decidido
dar la batalla.
Incluso antes de contar con el apoyo decidido
de la OTAN.
Recordad que, hasta febrero de 2022, la OTAN
había enviado unos pocos lanzamisiles Javelin
y ni siquiera permitía que se utilizaran
en el campo de batalla.
Y lo que es más importante ¿Es realista
pensar que Putin iba a quedarse con Ucrania?
¿Por qué no iba a ir a por otros países
que también consideran una amenaza existencial?
Por ejemplo…
los Bálticos.
Rusia ya ha lanzado ataques a países como
Estonia incluso después de entrar en la OTAN.
Ahí está el ciberataque del año 2007.
Dicho de otra forma: si el mundo es una anarquía
donde impera la ley del más fuerte...
¿Quién es más fuerte: Rusia o Estados Unidos?
¿Por qué Estados Unidos y Europa deberían
plegarse a los intereses de su antagonista?
T2 (VIEJAS, MUY VIEJAS IDEAS)
Vamos a ver otra conferencia que también
se ha difundido hasta la saciedad en el mundo
hispano.
En este caso hablamos de una charla de José
Antonio Zorrilla, que es un diplomático español.
Por resumir su charla: Estados Unidos lleva
décadas evitando que Rusia y Europa tengan
buenas relaciones ¿Por qué?
Pues atentos porque ahora sí que tenemos
que ir atrás en el tiempo.
Pero muy atrás.
Vamos a desempolvar una de las teorías más
antiguas de la geopolítica: la teoría del
Pivot Geográfico de la historia.
Esta teoría fue creada por el geógrafo HALFORD
MACKINDER en el año 1904.
Y dice lo siguiente.
(“El que domina Europa del Este, domina
el corazón de la tierra.
El que domina el corazón de la tierra, domina
la Isla-Planeta.
El que domina la Isla-Planeta, domina el mundo”
–Halford Mackinder)
¡Ya lo se!
A muchos os acaba de estallar la cabeza ¿Qué
es el corazón de la tierra?
Pues atentos a este mapa.
Lo que veis sombreado en rojo es lo que Mackinder
llama el corazón de la tierra.
También lo podéis encontrar en algunos libros
como “El Pivot Geográfico”.
Según Mackinder, quien domine este terreno,
domina la mayor parte de los recursos naturales
y las comunicaciones del mundo.
Eso significa que, si alguien dominara Rusia
y Europa del Este, incluyendo buena parte
de Alemania, dominaría el mundo.
Y por eso, Estados Unidos querría evitar
a toda costa una alianza entre Alemania y
Rusia ¿El problema?
El problema es que esta teoría podría tener
cierta validez…
¡En 1904!
Hoy en día, el mundo es totalmente distinto.
De existir un pívot en el mundo hoy en día,
probablemente estaría en el Sudeste Asiático
o en Asia Pacífico.
En la época de Mackinder, Asia no tenía
la importancia que tenía hoy en día.
La mayor parte de los países asiáticos eran
colonias Europeas ¿Recursos naturales?
Si hoy en día tenemos que hablar de recursos,
Oriente Medio tiene una importancia fundamental.
Sin embargo, a principios del siglo XX, el
petróleo no era ni de lejos tan importante
como lo es hoy en día.
Dicho de otra forma…
las teorías de Mackinder hoy en día están
totalmente superadas.
Pero hablando de teorías superadas, hay muchos
que aseguran que Ucrania está desempolvando
otras teorías que parecían haberse pasado
de moda para siempre.
Sí, vamos a responder a la pregunta que muchos
nos habéis hecho en mil y un comentarios.
Atentos.
T3(¿ES UCRANIA UN PAÍS NAZI?)
Lo habéis oído hasta la saciedad: la propaganda
rusa no se cansa en repetir que quieren “desnazificar”
Ucrania.
Y, lo cierto es que no sólo es
la propaganda rusa.
Muchos intelectual
Este señor es un embajador español: en principio
no tiene nada que ver con los propagandistas
rusos.
Y lo cierto es que…
¡Tiene razón!
De hecho, si veis algunos discursos de Putin,
veréis que hace alusión a los supuestos
“BANDERISTAS”.
Pues bien, estos son los seguidores de STEPAN
BANDERA, uno de los padres del nacionalismo
Ucraniano.
Durante los años 40, Bandera colaboró con
los Nazis en la invasión de Ucrania.
Este hombre fue responsable de limpiezas étnicas
y toda clase de violaciones contra los derechos
humanos.
Sin embargo, muchos ucranianos le consideran
un héroe nacional.
De hecho, recibió el título póstumo de
“Héroe de Ucrania” en el año 2010.
Curiosamente, este título se lo dio el presidente
prorruso Viktor Yanukovich.
Por suerte o por desgracia, la historia está
llena de personajes así.
Y muchos de ellos son elevados a los altares
por que “el enemigo de mi enemigo es mi
amigo”.
Dicho de otra forma, en el momento más duro
de las purgas de Stalin, las hambrunas provocadas
por Rusia para castigar en Ucrania y el HOLODOMOR,
muchos ucranianos se echaron en brazos de
los Alemanes ¡No sólo los ucranianos!
También Finlandia se alió con el III Reich
durante su guerra contra Rusia.
Suecia, que se mantuvo neutral durante la
II Guerra Mundial, permitió que los alemanes
cruzaran su territorio e incluso colaboró
con el ejército nazi ¿Significa esto que
Suecia o Finlandia sean países nazis hoy
en día?
Lógicamente no.
Y más en el caso de Ucrania.
Si estudiáis su historia durante todo el
siglo XX, entenderéis que han tenido todo
tipo de alianzas… y todas han salido mal
Por cierto, dentro de poco vamos a publicar
un vídeo en nuestro canal hermano, Megaprojekts,
donde vamos a contar con todo lujo de detalles
la historia de la primera guerra de Ucrania…
Si no estáis suscritos a Megaprojekts, no
sé a qué estáis esperando.
Os aseguro que este vídeo os va a dejar boquiabiertos…
y un poco deprimidos porque es una historia
para echarse a llorar.
En cualquier caso, las figuras políticas
cambian y se resignifican.
Si no, que se lo pregunten a los venezolanos.
La figura de Simón Bolívar se ha ensalzado
como un héroe del Socialismo del Siglo XXI…
Pese a que Bolívar fue un burgués de la
época criticado por el propio Marx.
La realidad es que, hoy en día, a diferencia
de otros países como GRECIA, UCRANIA no tiene
ningún partido nazi en su parlamento.
Como os podéis imaginar, en un país de más
de 40 millones de habitantes, hay grupos con
ideologías de todo tipo.
Y sí, es cierto, existen batallones dentro
del ejército ucraniano que sí tienen ideología
neonazi.
La pregunta es ¿De verdad alguien espera
que, en mitad de una invasión, el ejército
rechace a unos soldados sólo por su ideología?
Creo que todos entendemos que Ucrania en estos
momentos está dispuesta a reclutar a cualquiera
que quiera ir al frente a luchar.
Utilizar esto como argumento para demostrar
que todo el país está bajo un régimen nazi
es directamente vivir en un mundo paralelo.
Y llegados a este punto, turno para el debate
¿Consideráis que existen argumentos de peso
para justificar la invasión de Ucrania por
parte de Rusia?
¿Hasta qué punto creéis que la OTAN debe
comprometerse con Ucrania?
¿Deberían seguir enviando armamento?
¿Qué gana EEUU o la OTAN debilitando a Rusia?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Y, por favor, demostrad una vez más que la
comunidad de VisualPolitik es la más respetuosa
y civilizada de todas: discutid con respeto
y con argumentos.
Y como siempre, recordad que aquí seguimos
sacando vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.